se você já estavam entre as frestas
deste texto
e antes de eu escrever
em algumas porque questionar iam
e como eu mesmo a questionei
e a relação de um dos mitos fundadores
da ideia de europa com que se entende
por negridão ou por negritude
o e outras por que esperariam como eu
mesma esperei que uma poeta negra
parte-se da poesia chamada poesia negra
e não é dado às mulheres da dinastia das
veias lavadeiras cozinheiras
quitandeiras faxineiras papeleiras
falarem ou serem escutadas
e quando falamos
a nossa subjetividade é descartada em
favor de um suposto de um suposto
discurso negro
a nossa fala é tomada por conhecida
antes de pronunciarmos qualquer palavra
e além disso a outra dificuldade diante
da minha tendência e não apenas minhas
de querer abarcar o impossível
há de querer atender a dupla expectativa
que me prende que nos prende entre lados
aparentemente opostos o do figurino
negro e do figurino não medo
e ainda compartilho com vocês outra
dificuldade que inclusive me fez pensar
seriamente em estar aqui hoje ou não
estar porque o time pedem que eu
transforme o meu jeito de falar
o que utilize o dicionário mais próprio
para uma mulher negra
o que eu seja mais doce e menos dura que
eu seja menos formal e mais risonha
e sempre me acompanham as famosas frases
relativas a brabeza da mulher negra na
economia brava
eu já te me disseram vocês acreditam já
tenho me disseram que eu quero dar um
carteiraço
tá querendo tentando me passar por uma
mulher branca e assim então visitar os
salões da branquitude com esse meu jeito
de querer existir e de não apenas
existir como disse a professora fernanda
oliveira numa live enfim
a kelly que eu vista
é um figurino
e da suposta mulher negra
a minha tia bisavó joaninha era
costureira quem sabe até pudesse
costurar para mim e para quem queira
para quem quiser que melhor uma roupa
assim
é considerado tudo isso
o meu autorizei a transgressão de falar
hoje aqui em meu próprio nome
e talvez esse o motivo do excesso de
pronomes eu desde o início da minha fala
mas escutem
e não se trata de uma afirmação ególatra
egoísta massa o reconhecimento de que
assim eu posso porque outra já me
nomearam
e outras já me nomearam
a minha avó paterna e é poemas o seu
trabalho de doméstica seu nome herculana
o herculana
e esse nome desde sempre esteve
associado a uma narrativa épica me
refiro a hércules hércules soube que
poderia reparar expiar sua culpa pelo
assassinato de toda a sua família com
dez trabalhos com tudo dois trabalhos
dessa série inicial de 10 não foram
considerados um o que ele recebeu ajuda
de seu sobrinho e outro escutem bem e
outro a limpeza dos estados porque ele
recebeu pagamento assim desconsiderados
os dois trabalhos
e ele teve que a realizar dois trabalhos
adicionais e os dez trabalhos de
hércules se transformaram nos famosos
doze trabalhos de hércules
e no que deveria ser o seu décimo e
último trabalho roubaram uma manada de
bois mágicos vermelhos hélio o deus do
sol emprestou a hércules o seu carro
parte o herói pudesse então se deslocar
ao local da tarefa de um modo menos
desconfortável
e sujar o meu nome eliane
o hélio hélia eliane mas sem largar
inicia de marca
a herculano que marca o início de
hércules de hélio heated era o meu h se
perdeu
e na fronteira entre o brasil eo uruguai
onde eu fui criada se perdeu esse h
levado pelo vento de iansã
bom e até aí nessa fronteira chamada
fronteira da paz entre o brasil eo
uruguai eu estava emparedada entre o
português eo espanhol entre o ar elaire
então pessoal eu já entro nessa
narrativa com uma perda a letra h
e talvez até seja um ganho embora eu
continue emaranhada os doze trabalhos
impostos as mulheres de linha sucessão
de ginástica aqui outra aproximação com
herói trágico
e o trabalho tem o justo pagamento
é uma narrativa registrada no corpo de
nossas ancestrais e de várias de nós que
ainda nos movimentamos na sala das casas
ricas ou da classe média ou dos
escritórios ou das grandes instituições
inclusive públicas no trabalho
considerado de menor valor e
e entre as 12 horas em que se divide
cada porção do dia boa herculana
realizava 12 trabalhos assim como hoje
nós durante os 12 meses do ano também
realizamos 12 trabalhos sendo o tempo de
nossas vidas assim contado mas desses
doze trabalhos sempre se retiram dois
sem e se retiram dois e ficamos então
com esse sentido enganoso
o que somos menos de que nosso trabalho
vale menos
é de que nos falta algo na voz no corpo
no cabelo de que nos faltam figurino
adequado e que temos que estudar mais e
trabalhar mais que sermos mais
disciplinados e que temos que dormiram
menos e quem sabe até conseguirmos uma
costureira mágica para o tal figurino
com tudo por mais que o façamos esse
mais nunca nunca se mostra suficiente
para aquilo que queremos e para aquilo
que querem de nós
e até na negação de nossa mulher idade e
não sou uma mulher nos aparentam nos
aparentamos a masculinidade clássica do
herói até na força nós atribuída
inclusive para nos negar direitos somos
aparentados a esse semi-deus que talvez
não precisasse de ar e nem de dinheiro
os nossos trabalhos hercúleos parecem
ser insuficientes aqui entre eles os
anos
e parar
a respirar e jogarmos uma palavra ao
vento como diz o poeta ricardo aleixo no
poema palavrear eu jogo palavra no vento
eu jogo palavra no vento eu jogo palavra
95 vendo ela voar
e as palavras que pronunciamos calling
pesadas no pó dos livros das estantes de
outros
a mata aido cueca vegana
e no último trecho de um poema que eu
adoro chamada chamado uma saia de seda
ao sol this
e eu respirei
oi e me belisquei feliz de estar viva o
que você o que você é nós mulheres
negras ainda não fazemos isso respirar
bom e nos buscar felizes de estarmos
vivas
e assim como o sou neta de herculano
seus doze trabalhos de hércules pessoal
eu poderia ser bisneto ainda que postiço
da da intervenção do senhor zeus de
andrômeda
o que conversamos andrômeda foi uma
mulher cuja imagem semblante seu comprar
pessoa que tenha visto em quadros na
internet ou em filmes pensará que ela é
uma mulher branca mas o artigo a
andrômeda negra da historiadora de arte
britânica elizabeth mcgrath de 92 mostra
que os mitógrafo gregos definiram
andrômeda como uma princesa da etiópia
o que os gregos chamavam de etíopes os
polos de pele como a minha que o poeta
romano ovídio se refere a pele de
andrômeda como pele negra e que artistas
omitem sua negritude no todo da história
da arte ocidental porque andrômeda
deveria ser bonita e beleza e negritudes
são figurinos que não fecham
e são conceitos excludentes
a andrômeda não cabia no figurino que
queriam para uma princesa tiveram que
transformá-la em sua vida foi sufocada
pela mesma bota e pelo mesmo joelho que
tiram a respiração e a palavra que tiram
o sopro da vida das mulheres negras e de
seus rebentos
a andrômeda é nossa ancestral sufocada
pelas botas dos discursos dos anos assim
como outras de nós foram sufocados
é mas é por sua mão por sua mão etíope
e nenhuma solta não dá outra ou essa mão
negra agora resgatada é que vamos a
região da atual nigéria
é mas vamos com calma não podemos
caminhar um ano dois três pois já nos
negamos a sermos hercúleas
e vamos novamente parar
a respirar quem sabe pedir a carruagem
da divindade solar hélio emprestada
o e vejam vejam pessoal
em alguma alguma
e o roniel palmira um boletinho um mine
mine mine letra e vídeo é o link algum
poesia tradicional yorubá vejam pessoal
a lista algum o ferreiro
é um dia ao tentar violar sua mãe emo
algum foi surpreendido por seu pai
obatalá
e nessa tentativa terrível
é mas o próprio ogum se encarregou do
castigo foice para um lugar bem distante
viveu para o seu trabalho se afogando em
amarguras até que o show chegou e ogum
foi perdoado
é feito hércules ogum ou feito hércules
e ogum é possível que nós nesses doze
trabalhos que não são sempre 10 e
sejando estejamos espiando uma culpa
tentando reparar uma culpa e que culpa
será essa cometemos algum crime que não
possa ser apenado pelos meios ordinários
hércules em algum cometer um crime do
assassinato ou da tentativa de violação
de quem chama ele de sua gente a mãe a
esposa os filhos
e não importa não importa quantos
séculos tem se passado talvez conviva
conosco o sentimento de que não podemos
respirar enquanto gente nossa ficou no
fundo dos oceanos ou a flor da terra ou
nas valas comuns ou nos cemitérios
clandestinos enquanto gente nossa foi
branqueada ou cumprir pena mesmo sem
crime ou está agora mesmo com uma bota
no pescoço
nós sabemos olodumare mantém em segredo
e a tecnologia do sopro da vida que dele
de que dele emana mas apesar disso ele
não apenas permite mas ordena que
façamos uso desse sopro nas frestas
entre um trabalho e outro
os modelos respirar
e nos sentindo vivas podemos até nos
beliscar para sabermos se é verdade
e vivas podemos falar em nosso próprio
nome
nós temos a cabaça da criação em nosso
poder as palavras e falando em nosso
próprio nome nome haremos outras tantas
que se perderam e que mesmo no mundo dos
ancestrais nos ouvindo poderão respirar
e aqueles aquelas que morreram jamais
partiram estão na sombra que se a clara
e na soneca esses peça é um trecho
adaptado do poema sopros do senegalês
virar hoje o eu sou feita nós somos
feitas dessas vozes aquelas que dizem
que eu devo isso aquelas que dizem que
eu não devo ou devo aquele outro as
vozes que dizem de uma andrômeda negra
as que dizem de iansã de algum por isso
e como fizemos agora cada uma de nós
pode inventar o seu próprio mito com seu
próprio nome como seu nome próprio já
algum posto mas em tudo está determinado
cavando cavando o nosso lugar retirando
o excesso de terra um de água ou de
entulho aí poderemos nos res para lavar
e obrigada pela oportunidade de respirar
com vocês e por deixar ele de minhas
palavras assim sopr adas continue a
falar ainda que eu vento e quebrou-se
jogadas ao sopro do vento